[Music]
a new drug reduces the risk of heart
attacks by 40% shark attacks are up by a
factor of two drinking a liter of soda
per day doubles your chance of
developing cancer these are all examples
of relative risk a common way risk is
presented in news articles risk
evaluation is a complicated tangle of
statistical thinking and personal
preference one common stumbling block is
the difference between relative risks
like these and what are called absolute
risks risk is the likelihood that an
event will occur it can be expressed as
either a percentage for example that
heart attacks occur in 11 percent of men
between the ages of 60 and 79 or as a
rate that one in two million divers
along Australia's western coast will
suffer a fatal shark bite each year
these numbers Express the absolute risk
of heart attacks and shark attacks in
these groups changes in risk can be
expressed in relative or absolute terms
for example a review in 2009 found that
mammography screenings reduced the
number of breast cancer deaths from five
women in 1,000 to four the absolute risk
reduction was about 0.1% but the
relative risk reduction from five cases
of cancer mortality to four is 20% based
on reports of this higher number people
overestimated the impact of screening to
see why the difference between the two
ways of expressing risk matters let's
consider the hypothetical example of a
drug that reduces heart attack risk by
40 percent
imagine that out of a group of a
thousand people who didn't take the new
drug 10 would have heart attacks the
absolute risk is 10 out of 1000 or 1% if
a similar group of 1,000 people did take
the drug the number of heart attacks
would be 6 in other words the drug could
prevent 4 out of 10 heart attacks a
relative risk reduction of 40% meanwhile
the absolute risk only dropped from 1%
to 0.6%
but the 40% relative risk decrease
sounds a lot more significant surely
preventing even a handful of heart
attacks or any other negative outcome is
worthwhile isn't it
not necessarily the problem is that
choices that reduce some risks can put
you in the path of others suppose the
heart attack drug caused cancer in 1/2
of 1% of patients in our group of 1,000
people for heart attacks would be
prevented by taking the drug but there
would be five new cases of cancer the
relative reduction in heart attack risk
sounds substantial and the absolute risk
of cancer sounds small but they work out
to about the same number of cases in
real life everyone's individual
evaluation of risk will vary depending
on their personal circumstances if you
know you have a family history of heart
disease you might be more strongly
motivated to take a medication that
would lower your heart attack risk even
knowing it provided only a small
reduction in absolute risk sometimes we
have to decide between exposing
ourselves to risks that aren't directly
comparable if for example the heart
attack drug carried a higher risk of a
debilitating but not life-threatening
side effect like migraines rather than
cancer our evaluation of whether that
risk is worth taking might change and
sometimes there isn't necessarily a
correct choice
some might say even a miniscule risk of
shark attack is worth avoiding because
all you'd miss out on is an ocean swim
while others wouldn't even consider
skipping a swim to avoid an objectively
tiny risk of shark attack for all these
reasons risk evaluation is tricky at
baseline and reporting on risk can be
misleading especially when it shares
some numbers in absolute terms and
others in relative terms understanding
how these measures work will help you
cut through some of the confusion and
better evaluate risk want to know
something else humans are famously bad
at evaluating ourselves watch this video
to find out why so many incompetent
people think
amazing
[Music]